tu y vas avec moi ou sans moi
[Musique]
j'ai bel et bien vu ce que j'ai toujours
soupçonné de la part de sony wii poche
et j'ai vu lors n'a tenté vainement de
protéger son enfant
margaret gimié son fils et c'est ton
petit fils on veut retrouver un certain
données ou les boys
il est marié à la veuve de notre fils il
a emmené notre petit fils peut être
savoir que vous cherchez un oui boys et
vous trouverons on s'est dit autant voir
jimmy puisqu'on est dans le coin
puisque vous êtes dans quoi faites
attention on est tombés ou là on est
venu voir notre petit fils mon garçon
n'a pas de comptes à vous rendre comme
nous n'en avons pas à vous rendre
oh
[Rires]
rentrer avec mon nom ils me tueraient
lui et sa mère
votre petit fils
c'est un oui bon et maintenant
tu avec moi n'est ce pas je suis là pour
toi
il a frappé le renard le frappe et ta
femme
comme ça
commence pas si tu vas pas au bout